Thor: Love and Thunder will see Natalie Portman's
Jane Foster taking up the mantle of the Mighty
Thor, so where does that leave Chris Hemsworth's
Thor?
Here's everything we know, and everything
Marvel fans can expect when the movie arrives
in theaters.
Unless you've been living under a rock, you
probably know that the Thor in Avengers: Endgame
looks a bit different from the chiseled God
of Thunder we've seen in the last decade.
Sporting a luscious gut where his six-pack
once was, the latest version of Asgard's former
king was met with mixed reception.
So what does that mean for Thor: Love and
Thunder?
On one hand, it does make sense to take the
fans' criticism into consideration.
That being said, how exactly do you explain
Thor losing his dad bod while he's in space?
Unless Taika Waititi can come up with a feasible
explanation for how Thor slimmed down in the
time that's passed since the events of Endgame,
don't be surprised to see another round of
Bro Thor on the horizon.
Speaking of the Guardians, what kind of role
will they play in Thor: Love and Thunder?
Although Kevin Feige did confirm that there
will be a Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3 at
some point in the future, it's clear that
Thor's fourth solo outing will precede it.
Considering that Thor was last seen on board
the Benatar with the Guardians, is it safe
to assume that they'll also make an appearance
in Thor: Love and Thunder?
If they do, will there be enough screen time
to go around?
Don't forget that in addition to Jane Foster
becoming the Mighty Thor, the film will also
include Tessa Thompson's Valkyrie finding
a queen.
Thor's new space besties may need to take
a breather for the time being.
You know that awkward feeling when you see
an ex out in public?
Imagine how much worse it would be if that
ex was stealing your superpower.
In Ragnarok, Thor unconvincingly claims that
he was the one who dumped Jane when questioned
by some fans.
"Sorry to hear that Jane dumped you."
"She didn't dump me, I dumped her.
It was a mutual dumping."
Later, one of the MCU's go-to writers, Christopher
Markus, confirmed that Endgame almost featured
a reunion scene with Thor and Jane.
What's the deal with these star-crossed lovers?
It's worth noting that Thor's most successful
solo movie was the only one without Jane in
it.
Is it safe to assume that Waititi is going
to try a fresh new angle with the characters,
since clearly their romance wasn't translating
onscreen the way Marvel thought it would?
If so, don't expect much in the way of a rekindling
between these former flames, Thor: Love and
Thunder could instead find Chris Hemsworth
and Natalie Portman as friends and allies
rather than lovers.
"Oh, you know, Jane and I aren't even dating
anymore, so.
These things happen, though.
You know, nothing lasts forever.
The only thing that--"
"Why don't you come sit down-"
"I'm not done, yet, dude."
In a 2014 comic book event Original Sin, Thor
lost the ability to lift Mjolnir.
The trusty hammer was eventually picked up
by a cancer-ridden Jane Foster, granting her
the powers and mantle of Thor.
While the twist played out well on the comics
page, earlier Thor films have already played
withThor losing Mjolnir.
Hela reduces Mjolnir to pieces in Ragnarok,
and Odin even deemed Thor unworthy of his
hammer way back in the first Thor film.
Would Waititi yet again go down this seemingly
well-worn path?
If Thor: Love and Thunder includes yet another
instance where Thor's worthiness is brought
into question, there's a good chance fans
might perceive that as lazy writing.
The fraternal relationship between Thor and
Loki has been one of the best-developed arcs
in the MCU.
Tom Hiddleston's Loki evolved from enemy to
ally over the course of the three previous
Thor movies, and his early death at the hands
of Thanos in Avengers: Infinity War was a
sad moment for fans.
Although the time-traveling in Endgame opened
the door for more Loki in the future, it sounds
like he'll be limited to a series on Disney+,
and won't be interacting with the current
MCU timeline.
How will his brother's seemingly permanent
death affect the character?
Infinity War and Endgame explored the heavy
toll that excessive loss took on Thor's psyche,
and Loki is at the root of that.
Has Chris Hemsworth's Thor fully come to grips
with losing someone like Loki, or is a part
of him still in mourning?
Will Thor: Love and Thunder mark Chris Hemsworth's
final appearance in the MCU?
With Natalie Portman's Jane Foster taking
up the mantle, now could be an appropriate
time for Hemsworth to also pass the torch.
However, don't count your hammers before they
arrive.
"What am I looking at?"
"Sometimes it takes a second."
When speaking with Variety in May of 2019,
Hemsworth admitted that he wasn't ready to
hang up the hammer quite yet:
"I'd still love to do more, to be honest…I
feel like we've opened up such a different
character.
I feel more energized for the possibility
of where it could go."
Whether, Love and Thunder is Hemsworth's last
swing at the character or just another step
on Thor's journey, we'll just have to wait
for November 5, 2021 to find out.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.